and here's the thing though it's like to
some it's a competition right and in
many ways it is but I don't think it's a
competition between you me and like the
guy that I'm always compared to is with
Ken Jong or Eleanor the Asian guy right
and it's like and people try to get my
mind toward the competitive side of it
and to look us pit us against each other
right I just you know many times I'll be
like oh you know I'll see a billboard
with him in it in a movie or whatever
you know immediately my first response
would be to go inside myself and to go
what's wrong with you you're a loser
look he's killing it you're not you know
I mean but then I immediately go to it's
not comedy I love him I went to his
wedding he's my friend and then you go
through the like normal things it was a
smiling oh nothing tell me why you're
smiling picture of Ken Jong yeah yeah I
know exactly what your next step is what
is it do you really want me to say it
yeah but I will cut it out if it's weird
[Laughter]
totally still so the end it was all
right I feel like you we look at people
like that yeah and if we're being really
just transparent yeah here that's
because we know we're capable of doing
those things as well as good as our
quote unquote competition Wow my
competition is actually my accelerant my
competition is like how the Rolling
Stones used to bring amazing bands to
open up for them so they'd have to kick
ass [ __ ] more instead of putting
somebody who's kind of like you know no
interesting that you say that happen
yeah it's a lot of therapy dude
a lot of therapy help me shift the whole
universe of how I see I'm I'm more
introspective and I like I like I feel
more comfortable having these kinds of
conversations because it's we're all
evolving then you know it's we're all
we're evolving on a journey and what you
said that it's funny that you say that
because you know I've been bringing
openers on the road as of late then I
know I can follow that's not true
well no no the last couple of the last
couple have been really strong you had a
song yeah but they're not Fahim Anwar
you know he said straight A's Estrella
Fahim Anwar his
when they go before me there is glimpses
of me go backstage like you know but you
all that your window you walk in and
they go like this hey you're on next
after so and so and I've never seen you
be like cool good to go or I've done
this move oh no do you know I have
another spot somewhere else so I can't
even do it and they go are you really
where oh it's one night so one night I
mean like because he can call my line up
and it's like I may be something I used
to do that I don't do that anymore
like I honestly I I've if Rogan or
Bubber or a date or I followed you a
bunch of times in a school year yeah
I've I'm good about that now I think I
feel I believe I believe Canadian that I
can follow anybody I really do believe
that but on the road it's a little
different because of my audience and
it's also on pact and it's also they
don't expect someone like a Fahim Anwar
to be that good right he's clever he's
great joke writer you know his thought
processes it's all thought through the
bits and so at times I you know I've
gone oh my god this is but and I I
shouldn't but you know I've always been
able to follow them and I feel like
sometimes I bring weaker people so it
could make myself easier but I don't
think that that's that started probably
even as good probably no no why why
right right that's [ __ ] interesting
that you say that yeah you got it
I think your keep your back up against
the wall kind of guy I think you're
better when you're what you win you
think you're fighting for your life and
I'm like that too man I'm like that too
if I come into a situation and I'm
completely like kicked my feet up
comfortable I'm probably not gonna do as
well I'm a pressure player and I think
you're a pressure player which means I
don't know how you were in school but
days of tests I wouldn't even do my
homework ever at home but I scrambled to
learn it an hour before in studies those
were the ones I did well in yes I
planned and tried
all my [ __ ] DS why same with essays
or papers that I have to turn in it was
like if I if I planted three weeks in
advance that paper was gonna be [ __ ] but
if I forced myself to hours of
creativity under pressure yeah I would
bang out so best [ __ ] ever
we're pressure players man that's it
yeah that's so interesting you say that
because you're right like even like if
I'm on a set or something I'm doing and
I'm completely comfortable it's pretty
garbage it's it's when it's when like I
walk home like oh my god that was hard
yeah the kid gave me notes
right and I did it and they're like no
I'm not doing it right and then I walked
out off away for a bit came back I was
able to nail it but you know and then
it's like you're looking at that was
good yeah and the jobs where I come home
and I go that was the funnest time I've
ever had the ocean
and then we went I said you know play
and then it's a you watch it it's like a
YouTube video movie
[Laughter]
[Music]